welcome to this video play PD on pets
I don't know from Denmark let's see how
Linda's oh I could take it
I could try that if he takes 95 this
line that is gaining popularity recently
leading to the semi Tara Knight f3 now
is the semi Tara yeah yeah together flew
I calculate that so fairly solid found a
fairly solid opening for black the
structure is a bit similar to the green
felt but a difference of course is that
there's no fee engendered bishop but the
structure otherwise is quite quite
similar yeah he lost a bit of time with
them with Bishop d2 to d3 it's probably
not the end of the world but still
yeah what does flex idea what ideas that
have 2 against 1 on the queenside so in
some end games this might be might be an
asset and what's quite noisy and
generalists that I have a really wide e
5 have a really solid structure 5 my D 5
Queeny form
yeah it can get a bit dangerous he
really lost this temper but I still am
unsure how to proceed let's see if he is
doing something I want this was my idea
trying to get the Queen's off if he yeah
now I thought Queen f6 but not sure if
this is good okay let's do that
intending to to switch the Queen over to
h6 Knight g5 maybe he's going for that
straight away
h7 is is is threatened yeah this was
probably very bad play by me I mean of
course okay on g6 is not the dream the
exactly the dream scenario but yeah yeah
the knight coming to d6 is not it's not
what you what you like and Bishop to e6
looks entirely ridiculous it's not doing
anything there okay yeah I don't really
see what else
Oh rook takes rook takes I didn't expect
which does not mean it is bad but I
didn't expect it hmm yeah well Luke age
4 is it's quite substantial of course
hmm it's the technical wager play
against that can I go here and age six
maybe attacking this rook first and then
play age six very scary very scary
position
Jim I'm pretty sure I had analyzed it
afterwards that what is is able to do
something I mean maybe he's playing it
and just just punishing me but if he's
not pretty sure there is something it
looks very very dangerous
I have only some tricks available based
on the back rank mostly
yeah age six this was my idea that don't
look edge for I can take it
it's um if he moves the knight to f3 I
had that fire that's yeah this was what
I was mostly expecting because of night
F because of not f4 okay Queen takes e4
it's the simple oh yeah sometimes the
simple tricks really really are good to
have replied oh yeah look c1 made very
lucky very lucky game I was under huge
pressure at least I mean maybe maybe
black holes but I was really afraid it's
really afraid let's let's let's check
this what what the compass are giving
you know plus one point something 1.3
now it was to take with a knife though
does this seem to seem more
straightforward to me the knight on d6
is subtly a great piece always
controlling c8 and I really didn't know
what to do against that I start probably
play some rook moves but it's it's it's
a bit like whistling in the dark well
what are you doing there can can take
here yeah it's just just not good for
black I mean the night is so strong on
e4 and then on d6 and maybe this this is
actually a hold here conference to
retreat to you on yeah this shows that
and then play 94 yeah then rupee for
really wasn't the best after that h6
it did already give some gifts black
equality with Roxy salmon though here
there's Queen a3 good move
Queen a three yeah yeah it protects c1
it attacks a seven and what is my next
move there is this threat trapping the
Queen Wow
Queen a3 really would have would have
shocked me I would probably have
probably would have overlooked g4 even
the only movies g5 which is of course
really really ugly young white is in
excellent shape
this is why I'm Roxy 7s the computer
move protecting a7 beforehand so that
after the screen move I can I can play I
can play this with an equal position
complicated stuff yeah a very lucky game
he really missed some some great chances
I am probably right here I didn't really
have a proper idea what to do h6 looks
like normal but I was I was afraid that
this is this is some good for white when
I can make me just play here now I have
some some ideas on my own not instantly
because this hangs but yeah tricky I
don't have any experience in this
position type which really showed I
thought that it's maybe a good idea to
to get the Queen involved but it gets
into into real trouble him alright
thanks for watching